I'm thinking of your famous joke I want
you to do it but I went into a
restaurant that said they serve
breakfast anytime so I ordered French
toast during the Renaissance
[Laughter]
I have this always had this theory that
a good joke actually has weight like the
way an element does like it has you can
almost feel the weight of it in the palm
of your hand it's fascinating the
details of it all
you know not connected to time but that
French toast joke that was one of the
only jokes I ever re ever adjusted
because usually when I think of
something and I think of the word and
then that's it it's never changed but
that joke it wasn't first it wasn't the
Renaissance it was something else I
don't remember it was another reference
to time right but it wasn't the
Renaissance and then I thought well I'll
change it to the Renaissance and then be
connect the France French it connects
more yeah so it's just like it's
fascinating the details but what was
your method you'd sit would you sit and
and like I mean I'm fascinated by how
people do it do you sit with a a legal
pad
typewriter what were you doing I mean
and and you know you think I'm making a
joke with typewriter I actually do write
stuff on a typewriter because I don't
know I like yeah I have some old
typewriters and I just love the
mechanism of it and I love the kind of
um I think I think a little harder when
I'm working on a typewriter because it's
being put on paper and it feels like oh
it's more of a so it's like physical
combination of thing rather than a
computer yeah it doesn't little there's
an F physical F effort
I would in the first six months I would
get the newspaper out and look through
it and see if something would click like
to write
find a joke but then after like six or
eight months my mind became because it's
all based on what you notice right all
the comedy is noticing so my mind just
became noticing I didn't no longer
looked at the paper it was just like you
go out and you just notice and uh
it was uh like I have one of my favorite
jokes I ever did was I looking through
the paper and I saw electrolysis you
know an ad for electrolysis and I
thought what a word
the sound of that word is interesting
and what it means is interesting it's
not in my mind later came up with the I
lived in a building they allowed pets
and I had a pony I had a Shetland pony
named Nikki and he was involved in a
bizarre electrolysis accident all all
here was removed except for the tail now
I rent him out to Hari Krishna family
picnics
but you know I drew a lot before growing
Elementary School High School drawing
and painting
before I ever wrote anything and uh when
you draw something you notice
realistically if you like change to
abstract in my 20s but before that it
was real like so you really noticed
stuff like if you're gonna you're gonna
draw this glass in this bottle the shape
of the glass and the shape of the bottle
but the shape in between it is also a
shape and that helps you get it accurate
you know yeah to make it look real and I
think that
exercised my maybe my noticing abilities
like because it's just like all the
comedies from noticing you know in the
in the in the tower in the airport you
know the the tower they have with the
with the uh with the uh with the radio
the radar yeah so the radar sweeps like
this and then this little
dots of the planes so my subconscious
was scanning was scanning I'm not
walking down the street me I need
another joke I need a new joke I'm just
walking down the street but the scan is
going like this and it would just see
something a word or something
oh oh that's something yeah that could
be something I know that you're into
music and you're a musician and I think
it's such a there's such a connection
between comedy and music what I've
always heard is when I read about great
songwriters they just say that they're
doing the same thing they're scanning
and something hits them and I think it's
there and it can be anything but they're
reading the paper and then they see a
story and especially when you get doing
it enough where you you're making a
living even if you're just barely paying
the rent you're making a living from the
comedy you know a hundred dollars a week
that's three you know 300 400 Pages the
rent even less than unless so you have
time you have time you don't have to go
somewhere and do this this so you're
wandering around you know like a
four-year-old just wondering and to me
what you just said to me the world is
made up of like oh it's a giant Mosaic
painting it's little tiny fragments that
make up everything you know and he's
like here's that guy who died and that's
that's like a that's a tiny thing you
know and I've I've noticed things
where I combine oh this could be
connected this thing that has nothing to
do with this does have a common
denominator maybe in the in the word or
something then you combine I'm I'm not
thinking when I make it up I'm not going
like I'm not doing what I just said to
you
it's happening it's like oh that could
mean that it's a bang right thing yeah
it's really uh
cracks me up that my dad's a scientist
and he said once that um he's not a good
one
um
he's a shitty scientist we don't even
think he has a degree
walks around with a microscope that he
founds
around his neck like Mr T with a
medallion and he said I'm a sign and
then he just hang out at the train
station
eat grilled cheese sandwiches we were
like no he's a scientist but yeah but he
said like the job of your brain the
thing that's happened in evolution
that's supposed to Keep Us Alive is our
brain Making Connections that make sense
like huh he's got a fire here and I've
got meat here when I cook the meat it
actually tastes a little better I'm
going to start doing that and I think
there's something with the comedians I
really admire like you
there's almost something a miswiring
that that wouldn't work in evolution but
we're connecting things that shouldn't
be connected and my dad once said to me
and you know I've said it before but he
looked at me once and he said it's
interesting because he's very honest and
he's also very smart and he said you're
making your living off of something that
probably should be treated
and I realized he's not wrong that's
hilarious it's taking you know you can
have breakfast anytime or you know the
electrolysis joke you're taking things
and putting them together and they live
on completely different synapses that
aren't supposed to cross they're not
supposed to be touching each other yes
but something's either wrong or right in
a beautiful way and that's what happens
somehow you see a connection